瀧澤智瞬さんと
前田真理子さんでございます
このお二方に三宝の
ご加護がありますように
心が清らかになりますように
解脱に達することが
速やかにできますようにと
祝福致します
ではテーマに入ります
心を成長させること
英訳で言えば
Progress of the mindなんですけど
二つの方法で
心を成長しましょうというのは
かなり詳しく経典に書かれています
でも
それぞれ現代知識のアプローチから
一人一人解決しなくてはいけないんです
そうすると量がかなり
膨大になりますから
今日は何となく、何か
中身に入らないで紹介程度で
どんなものかなという紹介程度にします
実際にいろいろ瞑想のやり方は
結構時間かかりますが
それから
いろんな瞑想をすると
いろいろ体験が現れますから
体験というのは共通性はほぼ無いんです
個性があるんです
だからそれでちょっと
教える場合はすごく、あの...
私達は共通性を知っています
修行者が共通性を知らないんです
だからすごい気を付ける
セクションなんです
まぁそこら辺にとにかく
今日アクセスしない事にします、はい
Bhāvanāという言葉の意味なんですね
Bhāvanāというのは
成長、向上という意味になります
progressという意味になります
Bhāvanāは至って簡単に世の中では
瞑想ということに訳しますけど
そういうシンプルな意味ではないんです
progressという意味なんです
ですから例えば
技術、知識などなども我々は
いろいろ訓練して成長しますね
技術、すぐ一日で
できるものではないんです
知識も一日で
瞬間に知識人に達したということは
ありえないんです
じわじわとprogressして
成長して、向上して
いかなくてはいけない
分野はどうあっても
じわじわと順番で
成長していくことがそのプロセスに
Bhāvanāと言うんです
仏教の実践は心を清らかにする事
認識次元を超越する事と
心を完全に浄化することを目指します
仏教は仏教なりに
プログラムを持っています
カリキュラムを持っています
仏教のカリキュラムでは
心を清らかにする事です
まとめてみれば、皆様が暗記している
Sabbapāpassa akaraṇaṃ,
kusalassa upasampadā で
次の行は
Sacitta pariyo dapanaṃ
自分の心を清らかにすること
それはまぁ、ブッダのカリキュラムです
そこは３つで教えています
それからこの心とは認識する機能です
ここは本当に未熟で
全く成長していないんです
例えば1個の細胞の生命が
あるとしましょう
１個の細胞の生命にも
認識機能はあります
でもせいぜいどこら辺までできるか
という事は決まっています
それで私達は40兆の細胞を組み立てて
命になっていますね
我々の認識能力は
40兆がもう
共同、合わせて
働いてますから結構広い範囲で
認識することはできます
例えば単細胞には見る事は不可能です
光に何かしら反応する可能性はあります
でも見たわけではないんです
40兆が積み重なると
同じく光に反応する
でも反応は結構違います
それで、私たちの認識機能は
ただ単細胞の認識機能と同じく
ただそれは掛ける40兆になっただけで
成長したという事ではないんです
そこで仏教のカリキュラムは
この生命体の認識次元を
どんどん高くして
真理を発見するところまで
上げて上げていくんです
という事はこのだいたい単細胞で
考えるといいんです
単細胞は環境は感じている
光にも反応する、細胞の生活に合わせて
暗闇で生活する単細胞もいるし
栄養になるものも
何となく知っているし
別に栄養を探さなくても
栄養がある所に細胞が増えますから
そんな程度の能力です
いわゆるbasic, most basic
というability（能力）です
most basic functions
それが掛ける40兆って言っても
basic basic なんです
それで仏教では戒、定、慧という学
3つあるカリキュラムです
3つのステージで3段階で
心を成長することを教えています
そこでまず道徳を守る事
それは単細胞世界では関係ない
我々40兆の塊になったって
別に道徳はどうでもいいんです
食べる事、呼吸をして生きる事
嫌なものから離れる事
とにかく生存することで十分です
それしか能力がないんです
認識能力
道徳と言ってくれば
えっ？という事になるんです
でも道徳を守られますよ
ちょっと認識次元を変えておけば
例えば生命は生きるならば
他の生命に迷惑をかけてはならんと
別に、普通は
楽しむ、どうでもいいやと
いえいえ、それは良くないよと
ちょっとあえて他の生命にも
同じ気持ちを広げてみてください
そういう事で殺生するなかれと
他の生命と自分の中で
道徳セクションが入ってくる
みんな道徳が嫌いなのは
それで私が生きていきたい事に何か
プラスになりますかと
あまりプラスになるという事は
それほど感じない
それよりは
猪が走っているならば何か言って
倒してくれればありがたい感謝という
海のマグロを
捕まえる事ができれば何て幸せかと
幸せ感じるでしょう？
そこで他の生命に迷惑をかけているし
自分が食べて生きる事だけで
満足しているレベルなんです
だからどんな技術を駆使して
船に乗って
遠い海で魚を取ったからといって
立派な人間という事にはならないんです
道徳を守ると
ちょっと認識次元が
ちょっと変わります
そのように定と慧
定というのは集中力
パーリ語でsamādhiと言うんです
智慧の慧はpaññāと言うんです
この定と慧はbhāvanāいう言葉で
扱ってます
本当は戒もbhāvanāなんですけど
あまり伝統的にbhāvanāとは言わない
やっぱり、例えば五戒を守る事でも
毎日気を付けていないと
毎日自分の行為を観察してないと
そう簡単ではないんです
例えば嘘をついてはいけないとか
悪口はダメだとか
無駄話はダメと言ってしまうと
ずーっと喋る度にもう一つ
自分を自覚する認識が必要です
だから喋る認識と喋る事に対して
客観的に自覚する認識が
必要になってしまって
最初は失敗しますが
どんどんやってみると
認識レベルが高くなっているんです
だからそれもbhāvanāに入っても
構わないんですけど
一応伝統的にはこの
samādhi と paññā が
bhāvanāセクションでございます
はい次に行きます
はい、タイトルの説明はそれで終わり
それからこの
別な事を喋りたいんです
ここで私もちょっとこの
高い認識次元で物事を見て
内容を書いてありますから
そこでちょっと
理解して欲しいと思います
生命は物質を優先して生きています
生命と言うといつでも物質優先
例えば私という言葉使った瞬間で
肉体を指しているんです
肉体が優先です
皆様と一緒にどんな行動、活動しようと
まず体のことが先に
入り込んでしまうんです
成長を期待して
物質を組み替えたりします
ですから人間の認識レベルは
これだけですから
私とは肉体であり
というレベルですから
経典から皆様にそこは読めないんで
読んでみても、経典はあります
rūpaṃ me attā
attanīya va rūpaṃ
という風にブッダの専門用語で
何の事なく仰っている所なんです
rūpaṃ というのは身体
attāというのは我ですね
私とは身体であり
そこで我々知っている人間は
みんなそのレベルでいるんです
だからみんな
成長したいと思っているんです
という事はそのまま生きてみると
結構都合が悪いんです
ただ生まれたままで何か食べて何かやって
生きていると
ちょっと都合 が悪いんです
競争しなくてはいけないし
生存しなくてはいけないし
楽ではないんです
生きることは
そこで生きることは
大変だっていう場合でも
肉体のことを考えているんです
ですから人々は
成長しようではないかと思って
物質を組み替える
それだけ
食べなくてはいけない
原始人は手で獲物は取れないでしょうね
だから何か周り見ると
いろいろ
棘があるいろんな物を見つけて
それで刺したりすると
だから槍を使っただけで
物質を変えたんです
それが成長だと言うんです
それからこの...
石を削って
ある形で
武器を作ったんですね
よくあるhand axeというこの
何か特別な石で作って
それは形もあって
それで型があって
型に入れてこれなんとか削って
シャープな石、axeを使ったり
axeって斧でしたっけ？
hand axeで作ったりして
あれは成長しましたねとか
洞窟で住んでいた人々は
葉っぱでhut（小屋）を作ったら
結構成長したなとか
だって猿に未だにできないんですから
我々の一番近い親戚に
葉っぱあっちこっち持ってきて
何か作る事はできないんです
ただオラウータンだけは雨が降ると
大きい葉っぱを持って頭の上に添えて
傘みたいな感じで当てておくだけ
ちょっと考えてそこら辺で
葉っぱを2, 3 枚置いておけば
楽ちんで中に入っていられるでしょう?
そこまで進まないんです
それで我々、今生きている世界は
ITになっているでしょう？
物質を組み替えてるだけ
組み立ててるだけ
結局は全て電磁波でほとんど
成り立っているんだと発見したら
電磁波をいろんな方法で
組み立てたりするんです
AI時代、これから
もう始めたんですけど
これは、だいたい一般的には
人間の破滅が始まりましたと
まぁAIが勝手に成長したら
まぁ人間が潰れます
とにかくこの
IT、AI時代までは
我々は物質の組み替えですよ
やっていたのは
しかし心は
認識レベルは
そのまま
ITエンジニアであっても
認識レベルはそのまま
石器時代と同じです
何を食うか
ライバルは誰ですかと
誰と競争するのかと
それだけです
その人の競争相手は
別のITエンジニアかもしれません
でも原始時代でも同じ事で
心は成長もなくそのまま流れます
身体に触れる
色・声・香・味・触・法の波を
事実として認識します
昔も今も
体に六根がありますから
石器時代の人にも六根がある
オラウータンでも六根があります
六根に触れるデータが決まっています
色・声・香・味・触・法と言うんです
仏教専門用語で
専門用語がなければ
ちょっと説明は難しい
眼に見えるものに色と言う
オランウータンの眼に何が見えるか
チンパンジーの眼に何が見えるかと
これは知らないですけど
でもとにかく色と言うんです
昆虫の眼に
私たちと同じくは見えません
これ、どちらがよく見えるか
わからないんです
とにかくよく見える、幅広く見える
例えば昆虫やら蝶々には
紫外線まで見える
だから我々が赤い、黄色い色が
入っている花だなと思っても
蝶々には紫色も見えます
紫外線の
だから我々の見える模様と
ものすごく違うんです
だから蝶々の方が優れているとか
関係ないんです
あれは命を支えるために必要なだけ
ぱっと花を発見しないと
花蜜を飲めないんですから
だから、もうちょっと能力があったら
あるような気がしますけど
どんな花にも花蜜が（あるわけでは）
ないんです
花蜜を誰かが先に取ったら
その花が受粉しています
受粉したら微妙に花の形が変わります
人間にはその能力がないかも
ちょっと調べてできますよ
花を見たらこれは受粉してる
これは受粉してないとか
それはあまり教えたらいけないですね
やめます
蝶々にもその能力で花を見て
あぁ、これはもう
先に取られているんだと分かったら
別な花に行く事もできるでしょう？
私は蝶々と花を見たら
何かふわっと、んーっというあれ...
何か長い棒みたいなあれを入れて
ストローみたいなのを入れてみて
入れてみて、入れてみて
あぁ、無いと出て行くんです
あれ、無駄ですね
あっ、これは取られていると
先にわかったら別の花を探しますけど
まぁとにかくそれはそれで
だからどちらが偉いかではなくて
ただ肉体を維持する程度の
認識レベルです
だからコウモリには
超音波で見えますけど
だからコウモリ様はえらい
人間よりはとか
ではなくてコウモリはそれで
肉体を維持しているんです
だからこの肉体を維持するために
必要な程度で見える
必要な程度で聞こえる
それで吾輩はよく知っているという
あの態度
仏教ではちょっと
いい加減にしてくれない？
という態度なんです
とにかく我々は
色・声・香・味・触・法は事実である
えらい態度
だって何か見えたら、あるでしょう？
あるに決まっているでしょう？
テーブル触ったら硬い
硬いに決まっているでしょうとか
そういう風に自分が感じたもの
これだけあると言っても
蝶々はどう感じるか
オラウータンはどう感じるかって
これは知らない
そういうわけで私たちは限られた
色・声・香・味・触・法に触れる
そちらに限られているんだから
そちらの奴隷になる
依存する
それで結果は悩み、苦しみ、失望
次の漢字読めなくなっちゃった
衰え、別れ、死などで
命は回転します
そういう事からもう
離れませんね
蝶々さんにしても
咲いてる花の上に座って
ストローを入れてみたら
もう何もない
だから何となく
かわいそう
結構大変です、その世界は
花が咲いても蝶々たち、さーっと来て
ぱっぱっぱっと
花蜜を吸うんですけど
全ての蝶々にお腹いっぱいあるっていう保証はないんです
昆虫を取って食べている
ちっちゃな鳥たちでも
あちらへ行くわ
こちらへ行くわとか
そんなに、あっ、お腹いっぱい
という事には絶対ならない
私は毎日カラスの悲しい声を
聞いてますから
やっぱり食べる物がないんです
だからそれって悩みでしょう？
そろそろカラスさんも
子育てが始まると思いますけど
倍、エサが必要になるんです
自分もお腹が空いているのに
それで失望やら
特に衰えというのは身体、能力
身体は衰えていくし
また、死ぬでしょう
物質が私ですと思っている場合は
この奴隷で
そういう苦しみの循環もセットで
どうにもならなくなってしまうんです
そこで人間が
こんなことを妄想するんです
不可能ですが
これ、不可能です
物質を希望通りに変えることで
幸福、安穏が現れると
推測して生きています
だから
宗教世界も同じ
科学世界も同じ
芸術世界も同じ
何か変えれば幸せだと
例えば音楽家が曲を作る
あれって自然にあるものでは
ないでしょう？
音を希望通りに変える
これで幸せだと
だから
ただの色、絵の具と
言いたくはないんですけど
just colors
持って来て
あちらぺたぺたと塗って
何か作品を作って
どう、いいでしょう？とか
えらい事をやったつもりなんです
ゴッホでも誰でもいいんです
えらい事やっちゃったと
何をやったんですかね？
これで幸せになる？
最近になってきて
まぁ、地球外のどこかに
住むところを探そうとか
火星でも何か...
そんな夢まで見て
物質を希望通りに変えて
幸福になるという事は昔から同じ事
今の科学者がすごく
偉い事をやっているわけではないんです
例えば
QRコードで店でお金払ったりとか
俺が進んでいると
物質をちょっと変えただけでしょう？
ただ財布から
一千、二千円とか300円入るぞ
それはなくて
ピー、何とか音が出ますから
はい払い済、あぁ楽ちんだと
よくわからないですね
今、時計でもできるでしょう？
私は使ってない、機能はあるんですけど
やっぱりお金で払いますと
若者と一緒にいるんですから時々
時計あれ、ここ押して、こうして
はい、こうタッチして下さいとか
ほら終わりとか
あぁそうか
あまり、あぁ良かったねと言わない
無関心、わざわざ
はい、そういうことで
人間の
認識レベルはそんな程度ですね
やっぱり仏教の立場では
悪口ですけどこれは
あなた方は
まだまだ石器時代ですねとか
膨大、拡大してる
宇宙があるっていう事を
最近でしょう？発見したのは
可視光線でで見える宇宙と
そうでない宇宙がありますと
知ったのは
最近でしょう
お釈迦様は何の事ない
そんなの考えるのは面倒くさい
かなりありますからと
だから機械を使わないで
ウェッブ宇宙望遠鏡使わないで
宇宙のことを
淡々と科学者が発見する事より詳しく
喋っているならば
どちらの方が認識レベルが高いんですか
経典にはこの餓鬼の話がある
セクションがあります
サンユッタニカーヤにもありますし
クッダカニカーヤにも
テキスト、一つあります
阿羅漢たち、読んだら
餓鬼をそのまま見えるんです
飢える餓鬼たちが人間がいる所に
ここら辺にうろうろしています
そこで大きさは、こんな感じで
こんな形でとか
後で詳しく説明するんです
例えばここら辺で
10mぐらいの背の高い
口が上にある
いろんな形、変な体で
誰かいるとしましょう
そんなアホな話と思うでしょう？
だって我々に見える光線には
入らないんですから
もっと波長が
速い
あれも色として認識する
だからその餓鬼の話でも
認識レベルを超えた方々が
あまり一般人に言わないんですけど
やっぱり正念がある場合は言うんです
お釈迦様から阿羅漢たちが
アヌルッダ尊者か誰か
上のお坊さんが言ったんですけど
こういうことを言いましたよと
言うんです
そうすると大体お釈迦様の前で言う
あぁ、なるほど私もあの辺で
同じやつを見た事がありますよとか
はい、これは一般人間の立場
物質が私だと思っているんですから
そこで全て成長がストップしています
長くなってしまったんですけど
次のページに行きます
ここでいきなり仏教の世界
心こそ優先です、物質ではないんです
話をすごく短くしたいのですから
あまりブッダの言葉を引用してない
引用してしまうと
あの膨大な認識世界に
私もずっと引っ張られ...
ブラックホールに
吸い込まれるような感じで
吸い込まれてしまいますから
抜けられなくなります
だから気をつけて
チラチラっと簡単な所だけ
タッチしたんです
全ての現象の優先は心であると
お釈迦様は語ります
身体ではないんだと
心が優先であると
ここでManopubbaṅgamā dhammā
manoseṭṭhā manomayā;という
有名なダンマパダの第１偈と２偈です
pubbaṅgamāというのは
先に心があって全ての現象に
現象は後
Manoseṭṭhā
いつでも支配者、ボスは心です
現象ではありません
次の事、manomayā
というのは
made in Japan みたいな感じで
made by mind なんです
made in mineではないんです
全ての現象は
心が作っているんです
一切の現象は
心が作っているということで
心の働きによって
心が働くと心に
あるエネルギーが溜まるんです
心の法則と物質の法則の違う所は
物質を使うと
物質は衰えるんです
何でも使うと、例えば電気製品なんかは
使用期限とか保証期間は１年とか
あるでしょう
本当は1年以上使いますけど
どんどん使うと
能力が低下して低下して
使えなくなってしまうんです
心の場合はちょっと法則が違います
心を認識すればするほど
ポテンシャルというものは溜まるんです
いわゆるエネルギーなんです
心は物を作る度に
そのエネルギーを使っているんです
それが物質の現象を作ります
作る心が仕事をするという事は
見える、聞こえる、喋る等々でしょう?
歩く、座る、人をぶん殴るとか
心がやってます
いえ、人を殴るならば身体でしょうと
私があなたを殴ってないよ
私はあなたを殴るつもり全くないんだよ
身体がやった事には私は責任持ちませんよと言える？
この物体があなたを殴った事に
私は責任持ちません
いいえ、物体を動かしたのは心です
それでポテンシャルが溜まるんです
ですから我々生きている場合は苦しく
苦になったり、楽になったりします
不幸になったり、幸福になったりします
あれも相対的で
定義は、はっきりしません
自分があぁ、幸福だと思うだけで
例えば歩こうと思ったところでちょっと歩くと疲れてしまって
やっぱりタクシー拾おうと
思った途端タクシーが来る
それでぱっと止めて良かった、ぴったし
タクシー拾おうと思ったら
タクシーが来て乗れた
あぁ、幸せだと思うでしょう
次の日また買い物に散歩していると
タクシーが行くわ行くわ
うるさいね今日は渋滞で
ということになりますね
だから
幸せを感じる、不幸を感じるとかは
いつだって相対的です
Manasā ce paduṭṭhena
心が汚れてるならば
汚れた心が仕事をして
ポテンシャルをする
ポテンシャルを溜める
Manasā ce pasannena
清らかな心で
輝く心で行為をして
ポテンシャルを溜める
このポテンシャルは2種類になるんです
溜まったエネルギーは
ですから汚れた心の
で溜まったポテンシャルが
物質を作る場合は
全部嫌な物質、あって欲しくない物
清らかな心がやった
仕事をして
儲かった財産で物質を作る場合は
欲しい物ばっかりです
それで幸、不幸という事は
成り立つんです
これ理解できなかったら
皆様の仕事で考えてください
仕事をすれば
その人の会社で日にち違いますけど
給料をもらえます
もらった給料で
好きなように生活できますが
好きなようにもできませんね
自分の楽しみは給料に合わせなくては
いけなくなってしまうんです
もっと楽しみたいんだけど
お金が足らないという事もあります
はい、そんな事で
心が優先で働いてますよと
だから心の事を考えなさいよと
携帯のバージョンではないんです
携帯がなくても生きていられます
私みたいで、面倒くさいんだから
いつでも人に頼む
これメッセージ入れて
あの人からこういう事を今訊いてとか
どういう事？
ちょっと写真を送ってもらって
若い連中は
はい、わかりましたとすぐ出して
これですと見せてくれる
あぁそうか、終わり
私は七面倒くさい事はしません
はい、次に行きましょうか
これで
仏教はこの無常
無常、無常と言いながら
教えているのはquantum世界なんです
昨日も夜ちょっと経典を読んで
超越した智慧の法に
アクセスして読んでみたんですけど
やっぱりquantum世界だなと
これはもう公で紹介できません
難しいし、見てね
生命は自分の心が作った
物質の世界に生きているんです
我々一人一人が、私が
私の心が作った世界で生きているんです
これ物質世界です
他の生も同じです
物質、心が物質を作るんだと
ということは物質は存在するか
しないかはその心次第でしょう？
全くquantum世界でしょう？
伝統的な物理学とはまるっきり違う
quantum physics、世にすごく一般的に
知られるようになる前
経典にあるものを全部嘘、インチキだと
昔の仏教学者たちは
へっちゃらで言っていたんですから
ですから
これ、例に出したんで
私に楽しい現象は
他人に楽しいわけではないんです
ネズミの死骸は
カラスさんにはご馳走ですが
私にとっては気持ち悪くて
食欲もなくなるくらい気持ち悪くなる
だからネズミの死骸は
カラスに幸福をもたらすが
人間には不幸、嫌な気持ち
作ってしまうんです
もっと心配に言えば
こちらにネズミの死骸がある
死んで2日間も経っていて
ちょっと臭いもする
そこでカラスも私も見る
カラスは幸せを感じているでしょう？
カラスさんにとっては
善行為の善果なんです
それを見ている私にとっては
悪行為の悪果なんです
だって気持ち悪くなって
しまったんですから
あぁ見たくない、臭いも酷い
苦しみを感じているでしょう？
苦しみを感じたのは
悪行為の結果なんです
カラスが、あーっやった！
美味しいものを見つけたと
だから1秒の
0.1秒でもカラスは
あれを取って終わってるんです
それで悪業、善業の差がわかる
それから私が知っている世界
これは本当の世界か
普遍的な事実か
これ、わからないんです
よく私はネットで
自分の何か、面白いんですから
望遠鏡のガスをいろいろ見ながら
これって本当なのかね
あの連中の妄想ではないかとか
だって全部シミュレーションして作った
画像ですから
かなりそこでインチキが見えてきます
というわけで
まぁ、わからない事実、真理は
自分が作ったバブルの中で
生きているんです
以前の行為で溜まった
ポテンシャル・エネルギーが
今の物質現象を作るので
今経験する現象の世界を今の気持ちで
希望で変えることは不可能です
これ覚えておいてください
例えば私はこのマイクロフォンを見る
見たらマイクロフォンの色が
気に入らない
金属色であった方が良かったとか
その色のマイクがあるでしょう？
アルミ色の
私が、はい金属色になってと
言ってもなれる？
なれません
ずっと私が気に入らない色で
そのままでいるんです
心が作るんだったら
これ、色が変わるはずでしょう？
変わらないんです
だからみんなそこを
錯覚、誤解するんです
高い枝に木の実があって
取りたいんですけど手が届かない
枝がもうちょっと20cm下に
あった方がいいなと思ったら
枝がずずっと下がって
20cm下になるならば楽ちんでしょう？
スリランカの場合は例えば
ココナッツという
棒みたいに木が伸びるでしょう？
あぁココナッツを取りたいなと言ったら
ココナッツの木が
ギューッと曲がってきたら
はい、取ってまた木が元に戻るならば
あんまりにも楽ちんね
希望通りに
そうならないからみんな物質は
独立して存在すると
錯覚しているんです
科学者もそう思っているんです
traditional physics の場合は
伝統的な物理学世界は
これでポイントは私の心の
ポテンシャルが物を作るんです
ポテンシャルは
過去で溜まった物でしょう？
それはもう変えられないんです
例えば昨日、私は人に悪口を言った
ポテンシャル溜まった
今日、何か人々の態度が違う
私に嫌な態度をする
失礼な態度をする
それでは私はもっと
柔らかい、美しい態度に変えなさいと
変わらない
なぜならば、このポテンシャルは
昨日作ったんですから
昨日作ったポテンシャルの結果が
今に出るんです
今思う通りに今の現象が変わるならば
そんなに難しくないんですけど
このポイント理解するために
今思った事の結果が後で出ます
今、悪思考したら
あぁ嫌だみんなもう
本当に気持ち悪い連中だ
もう二度とこのオレンジみたいな
人間に会いたくないんだとか
独りでいた方が楽ちんだと思ったら
でも毎日何の事なく
人間と一緒に生活しますよ
でも時間が経った所で
ぱつんと独りぼっちになってしまって
その時に限って人の助けが必要になる
人の助けが必要だけど誰もいない
人がいてもみんなそれぞれ忙しくて
助ける状況ではない
その時何て私は不幸だと思っても
あなたが過去でやった事の結果なんです
今このポテンシャルを説明しているのは
業の働きなんです
心に業という法則が働いてます
業の法則は普通の知識で理論で
分からないのは
結果がすぐ出ないこと
要するに心は物を作るんですけど
心が自由自在ではないんです
心も
条件の中で仕事をしなくては
いけないんです
お釈迦様は業の話はあまりガチャガチャ
考えてる必要はないと
これはちょっと人間には
理解難しいと言ったのは
一つは時間のポイント
お釈迦様はこう言うんです
悪行為をしたら
その瞬間で悪結果になるならば
誰も悪行為をしませんと
でも悪行為が火種みたいに溜まって
ジワジワジワジワと
条件が揃ったら
ドカーンと出てくるんです
結果出る時間設定はいつでも不確定です
quantum世界ですけど
そちらにも因果法則があるんです
ですからね、今瞬間で結果が出るならば
買い物をしてもお金がない
そうすると手帳一枚取って
はい、1万円になりなさいと言ったら
手帳1枚1万円になる
それではい、これで
それは成り立たないんです
なぜなら、そうすると
逆もできますからね
私はお店の人に1万円札を出したら
お店の人はこれティッシュに
なって欲しいと思ったら
これティッシュになってしまったら
どうしますか
すごいですよ
でも物事は希望通りに行きますよ
時間のラップがあるんです
だからみんな希望通りに
行ってないと思っているんです
地獄に落ちて苦しんでいる生命は
希望通りで地獄に落ちているんです
野生の生命ですごい厳しい環境で
苦しんで生活する生命
それ希望通りなんです
希望はすごい別な時間で
やったことなんです
だから行為をするというのは
石を投げたことで
石を投げたら
話にならないそれから
投げてから石の何て言いますか飛び方を
ちょっと調整する、できません
落ち方、あっ人の頭に落ちそう
ちょっとずらして、できません
投げる前にそれを 考えた方が良かった
投げる前に角度とどこら辺に落ちるのか
考えた方が良かったんです
投げたらもう軌道を変えることも
落ちる場所を変えることも不可能です
業の場合はそういうことで
行為をしたらポテンシャル溜まった
さようなら、話おわり
それから結果が出る
はい
業の法則、今説明したんですけどね
自分が定められた
固定された世界に生きていること
自分の性格・思考パターンが
決まっていると感じてしまいます
何かみんなそう思っているんです
何か自分の命は固定されて決まっている
もうどうしようもないと
好まないものや気に入らない人を
好きなもの・気に入る人に
変えられないと思っているし
経験もしています
気に入らない人がいるんで
やっぱりこの人を
気に入るようにしようかなと思っても
あまり気に入らないと気に入らない
という事は全部、定められているような
錯覚が起こるでしょう？
しかし業では全て定められているとは
言ってないんです
あれ、時間のラップで
この錯覚が起こるだけで
例えば人を侮辱したら、行為でしょう？
侮辱はどんな結果出すかその瞬間で
決めて終わっているんです
でも侮辱を受けた人が
気が弱い人で落ち込んで
泣きながら帰ったとしましょう
俺が他人を侮辱したんだけど
何の結果も俺には無いんだぞと
威張るでしょう
俺はパワハラやってるんだけど
あなた方何様のつもりですかと
私をどうする事もできませんよと
その時、結果が出ません
タイムラップがあります
これは定められたタイムラップでは
ないんです
条件が揃った途端
結果が出ます
例えばこちらにすごい破壊力がある
ダイナマイトがあるとしましょう
別にダイナマイトは
何のこともないでしょ？
それを転がすこともできるし
その上に乗ってみることもできるし
全然へっちゃら
子供はそれを持って遊んでも
全然大丈夫です
でもこのダイナマイトに
建物一つ破壊する
ポテンシャルがあるんです
なのに子供があれを持って
刀の...
みたいな感じで
これは戦いだ、あれやこれや
自分の兄弟の頭を殴って
お前の負けだとか
遊んでおもちゃにしたって
全然、大丈夫です
しかし
何かのわけ、理由で
導火線に火が
ほんのちょっと入ったらどう？
建物は全部破壊する
だからタイムラップは計算できません
このダイナマイトが10年と3カ月と
11日と3時間30分経った所で
爆発すると言える？
言えないんです
条件がいつ揃うか分からない
時々私は他人を侮辱したら
その場でバツンと殴られたと
その場合はすぐ結果でましたね
それだけではなくてお前会社クビ
明日から仕事なし来ないでくださいと
その場で警察に訴えて
法律的に処分するんだよ言われたら
結果はその場で
そうでない場合もある
これって業の面倒くさい所で
まぁ早く行きましょう
業の話ばかりで
それで、私はこの業は
定められてないという事に
認識レベルを上げる事、世界ですから
今も皆様の認識レベルを上げる目的で
いろいろデータを出してます
科学では業は発見しないでしょう？
仏教だったら、ごく当たり前の話
もうすぐ経験、証拠済み
実証、立証するという
そこで例を出しました
次に花を見ましょうかね
目を開けて花を見てしまうと
皆様に見える花は過去の業の結果です
だからいろんな人にどんな風に
この花でもいいんですけど
どんな風にこの花が見えるかと
私は知りませんよ
一人一人は自分に見える花が
それが現実、事実世界だと
今認識しているでしょう？
それ業でしょう？
業、変えられます
先ず、自分の感情が作った花が見えます
今、皆様方には自分の感情
自分の業が作った花が見えます
これはきれいかもしれませんし
よくわからない
ゴージャスに見えるかもしれません
何の事もない花だと
見えるかもしれませんよ
皆様の業ですから
ゴージャスな花だ
感動しましたと言ったら
その人の善行為の結果です
お前、馬鹿ではないか
ではないんです
どんな、何だ、ただ単に花の束でしょう
面白くないと思う人の
業の結果です
その人にもこの僅かな...善
花を見ているのは気持ち悪くは
ならないんですから、人間には
だから僅かな善行為の結果なんです
だから花を見たところで
業が働いています
これは定めたプログラム
もうちょっとやってみましょうか
これから詳しく見てみましょうか
花をじーっと見る
感情を抜きにして
理性を使って
そうすると別な花が見えてくるんです
見方はいろいろ
では色で見ようかなと
前に座っている方々で見て、この花でも
では色別で見ようかなとか
前と違うでしょう？
あっ、きれいな花だ
感動しましたではないね
例えば赤い色はこちら、こちらにあって
赤いのもいろんな赤があります
黄色い花もあるんですけど
黄色も何通りもあります
色中心に見る事、形中心に見る
はい、次のプラクティス
形で見て下さい
この花はこんな形
この花はこんな形で
別世界でしょう？
だからぱっと、ぼけっと見ることを
変えられるでしょう？
これは一輪の花を見て実験した方が
ものすごく分かりやすいんです
つまらない花だとね
例えばタンポポみたいな
今あちらこちらで
いろんな花が咲いているでしょう？
雑草で
私のいるところでも
ドクダミの花、つまらないあの花は
観察してみて下さい
かわいいんですよ
ちっちゃくて
あまりおしゃれがなくて
シンプルで
しっかり形を整えてかわいい
かわいいと思う私の業は何ですかね？
タンポポを見たら
タンポポの花って
普段こういうところに来ないね
品格低い
でも1本、一輪のタンポポを見てください
じーっと観察して
いかにかわいいかと
いかにかっこよくできているのかと
つまらないと思ったんですけど
あの色が自分が生きる環境に
適している事
そうすると賢いなとわかるんですよ
だから皆様方はこの主観をやめて
感情を止めて観察したら
その場で業が変わっているんです
ご飯、口にいれると馬鹿みたいに
あぁおいしいと、あぁまずいと
言うのではなくて
この感情を置いておいて
感触はいかがでしょうか
噛み具合はいかがでしょうか
どんな、どんな味が入っているのか
味と言っても6種類、5種類でしょう？
こういう風に分けてみたりすると
別な世界が生まれます
だから業は変えられます
私はこの瞑想の世界でBhāvanāの世界で
観察瞑想を教えているでしょう？
あれで業が変わります
今ちょっとサンプルで
業論を教えると
みんな仏教は何でも業だと
言ってるんだよと
何かすごくみんなネガティブに
見るんですよ業の話は
これ、quantums論 なんですよ
だからお釈迦様はバカにわかるわけないと置いといているんです
はい次に行きます
それで
育てられるのは心です
物質ではないんです
物質は組み立てるだけ
成長できません
例えば鉄を成長させて
銅にする、銅を成長させて銀にする
できませんね
銀を成長させて金にする
まぁ素粒子でかなりやれば可能です
だって金の原子の周り
どれぐらい、あれ回っているのかと
原子はどれぐらい重いかと
どれくらいelectron, neutron
あれやこれやと入っている
入れてしまえばいいでしょう？
例えば鉄の原子を持って
それに外から
proton入れたり、electron入れたり
あるいはneutron入れたりとか
変えたら金でしょ？
でもできないねこれは
できたとしてもただの組み立てだけです
本来は金があるわけでも
銀があるわけでも
銅があるわけでもないんです
しかし心が成長できます
我々もね生まれた赤ちゃんの時から
どんどんどんどん
心がある程度で物質依存でも
ある程度で成長してきたでしょう？
人は物質を組み立てること
物質に価値を入れること
物質を自分の所有物にすること
物質を破壊しようとすること
ばかりやっています
成功しませんよ
進んだ錯覚があっても心はそのままです
いろいろ頑張ってますよ
建物作ったり
北朝鮮でロケットを作って
日本海まで
発射させたり
こいつら猿のまんまなんです
私達もそうなんですけどね
北朝鮮と大した変わりは
ないんですけど
しかし心を向上させること
成長させること
清らかにすることならできるんです
心の戒めはバーワナーと言うんです
心を成長させていることに
バーワナーと言うんです
例えば金属にいくら水を入れても
いくら肥料を入れても
銅にはなりません
銅というのはcopper、にはなりません
あるいは金にはなりません
でも同じ物質で種一つ持ってきて
土に植えて水をあげて
ちょこちょこっと待っているとやっぱり
成長して全く別なものに
変わってしまうんです
種見たら
何かわからない
育ててみたら
すごい立派な植物になって
枝が伸びて美しい葉っぱが
いっぱいあって花が咲いて
実るものだったら実ったり
すごい結果がでます
心は成長できます
ですからその例えで覚えてください
物質が優先であるということは錯覚だと
理解するならば誰でも成長します
まず皆様にハンディがあるんです
これを外してください
物質はすごいと
物質は偉大なりと
いえ、物質は心が作っているんだと
本当は素粒子の世界はquantum世界だと
心がないと成り立たないんだと
それを知ったら
心は、ぱっぱっぱと
成長させることはできます
でもそれは、すごい世界だからちゃんと
心を成長、完成した人から
方法を学んで、すごい丁寧に
やらなくてはいけない
例えば飛行機の操縦士
になりたいんだったら
そこら辺で運転免許を取ったからって
意味がないでしょう？
あるいはコクピットに座って
ボタンを教えてもらって
メーターの事を教えてもらって
だから飛べる？
それはしっかりした訓練
プロから訓練を受けてもらわないと
怒鳴られるわ、貶されるわ
馬鹿にされるわ
結構大変ですよ
いろんなテストで落第するわ
またやれと言うわ
例えば医学とそういう飛行機とかは
100点満点でなければ
アウト
あなたはもうだいたい80点で
例えば飛行機の操縦訓練して
80点、あぁ合格
ないんです
100点にならないと
私はちょっと
シミュレーションをやってみて
教えた人の反応は
あなたみんな殺しちゃったねとか
あなたはみんなを
下ろしてしまったねとか
すごい丁寧に教えてもらったんですよ
操縦のやり方
私がやったら、みんな殺しちゃった
はい次に行きます
ではバーワナーは2種類ですから
サマーディバーワナーをまず紹介します
Samādhi meditation
物質優先という錯覚から離れる実践
サマーディ瞑想っていうのはすごい
初期的で
quantum世界に紹介するんです
招待でしたっけ？
紹介ではなくて招待するんです
アインシュタインはじめ
偉い学者、科学者たちも
quantum、あり得ない、嘘
こんなspooky世界はないんだとか
言っていたんですけど
我々もそうやって物質はすごいと
あなたの説法聞くよりは
晩御飯の献立考えた方が
幸せだという態度でいるでしょう
それを変えるだけで
至って簡単でしょ？考えてみれば
はい次に行きます
まず俗世間が知っている
瞑想があります
それはちょっと説明します
知っているサマーディ
Weedsなどを使って
別世界を感じる人々もいます
Weeds、知ってますね？
よく知ってるみたいね
使っているでしょうね
Weedsは雑草という意味ではなくて
Marijuana
あれは薬用の普通の植物です
人間がこれ
吸ったりいろいろ加工、物質作って
服用したり注射したりすると
かなりサイケデリックな
世界が現れるんだと
アメリカであるバカが
いたんです、科学者で
瞑想の世界で
麻薬で体験できないのかと言って
学生さんたちに
麻薬を使ってこれは瞑想だと
理論も同じです
身体優先ということが
肉体が優先ということを
何とかして抑えてもらう
様々な行を通じて異次元世界を
経験しようとする人もいます
いろんな行、ありますね
山を登って降りて
また登って降りてとか
険しい山に登ったりとか
インドに行って、ネパールに行って
いろんな山に登ったりとか
あるいは信仰する宗教の祈り
呪文などを使う人もいる
私が知っている範囲ではイスラム教と
キリスト教の世界ではこの祈りを
イスラム教ではコーランのいろいろ
フレーズをずーっと念じるんです
念じて何か神秘体験を
得ようとするんです
キリスト教の世界では
決まった祈りのフレーズがありまして
それを...例えば普通の教会で一般人が
ものすごい「ハレルヤ」って
泣き叫ぶでしょ？
喉から血が出るほど
あれも、ハレルヤ、ハレルヤ
とか言いながら
何か変な神秘体験を得たいんです
変なという事は私の偏見ですけど
何か神秘体験を得たいんです
神秘体験があったら
やっぱり神様がいるんだという
決まりになるんです
証拠ではないんですけど
それから音楽、踊りなどを
手段に使う人々がいる
これは全部、瞑想のカテゴリーです
皆様今、最近日本でないんで、あの
Hare Rama Hare Krishnaというグループは
あのグループは太鼓と
何か楽器を使いながら
Hare Rama Hare Krishna
Hare Krishna Hare Rama
そればっかり、一日中歌っているんです
時々ちょっと踊ったりもするし
それでヨーロッパ人の文章で
読んでみたら
結構、神秘体験を受けたとか
昔ブッダの時代で
特にジャイナ教などは
断食で神秘体験を得ようとするんです
これイスラム教の断食と違いますよ
本当に断食なんです
イスラム教ではラマダンという月で
みんな体重が増えるんです
これは悪口でない、イスラム人の中でも
それは冗談で使うんです
特に女性の方々は
真面目に断食するんです
でも体重を計ってみたら
増えているんです
それはどういう事かと言うと
日が...何と言いますか
日が暮れたら、ご飯食べるんです
ハチャメチャ食べるんです
また日の出前にストップ
それから唾液も飲み込まない
何と言う...夜はもう...
まぁ、それはそれでいいんですけど
そういう断食でも
そういう人々は何かちょっと
清らかな精神になったなとか
断食の間では性行為はしませんし
すごく真面目ではいるんです
それから苦しんでいる人々を
助けてあげたり
貧乏な人々にお金あげたり
寄付したりとか
結構いろんなことはやってます
だから本人たちがすごく何か
清らかな気持ちを経験しているんです
神秘体験まではないかも
イスラム教で神秘体験を得たくて
頑張っているグループは別にいるんです
あの踊るグループは何ていいますか？
スーフィーとか
音楽家なんかは
本当に能力がある音楽家たち
新宿で歌ってる
あの子供たちではないんです
時々、お前家に帰れ
帰って寝なさいと言いたくなるぐらい
それでも頑張って欲しいんですけど
すごい、時々出ます
すごいかっこいい音楽が現れます
現れたらそれは
みんなそれを使ってしまうし
その人々は何か...
別にいるんです
人間ではないんです
何か変です
あれは音楽として
身体に依存すること
色・声・香・味・触・法に依存することをカットしているんです
そういう事で世の中でも俗世間でも
瞑想みたいなサマーディー瞑想の
グループに入るものは
結構たくさんあります
インドのヒンドゥー教で
未だにいろんな種類の麻薬を使って
西洋の麻薬ではなくてインド伝統的な
麻薬はいくらでもありますから
あれを使って
神を体験しようと頑張ってはいるんです
仏教というのでは悪口になる...
私は日本人一人知っているんですけど
いい加減でインドに行ってしまって
どこかでちょっとそういう経験があって
麻薬ではなかったんですけど
本人が、だから大丈夫だと
私はあっ、これはまずいと
ヒンドゥーテンプルがありますね
テンプルの中に入って
ちょっといてしまうと
ちょっと雰囲気が変わるんです
これはやっぱり宗教的な
免疫が無い方々は
気を付けた方がいいんです
私が行っても大丈夫です
すごい免疫を持っていますから
テンプルの中に入ってしまうと
まず窓がないんです
当然、線香と明かりを
たくさんつけてあるんです
それで太鼓やらお輪を
ギャンギャン、ガチャガチャ...ずっと
麻痺するぐらい、耳が
そこは耐えられなくて
脳が
機能停止するんです
その時何か現象が起こるんです
これは...その人は自分の偉大なる
神秘体験を喋っていたんですけど
私は、あっこの人の脳みそは壊れている
もう治せなくなってしまったと
悲しかったんです
もう直せないんだと
治せない所まで壊れてしまうと
その世界の危険性は
この壊れる所が一番肝心な所で
もう直せなくなる場合もあります
宗教たくさん
インドヒンドゥー教っていうのは
一つの宗教ではないんですから
宗教コンプレックスだから
マンションみたいなもので
たくさんの人が住んでいる
そちら辺で誰だっていろいろ
免疫を持っています
だから大丈夫です
そういうわけで
例えば西洋的に麻薬を使って
サイケデリック経験になってしまったら
脳みそが壊れる可能性があります
純粋なWeedsは
あまり危険ではないんです
吸っても
marijuanaですね
あれは葉っぱを
タバコみたいにして
吸ってもそんなに悪影響はないんです
脳のシステムは壊れないんです
それは元々あれ
薬用のものだから
薬をみだらに使っているだけで
あれは細胞を復活させるために
いろんな他の薬と合わせて
使うんです
決して薬世界では吸わないんです
絶対しない、その代わりに
食べる薬、いろんな薬を使って
食べたりはするし、それで
細胞が壊れている所を修復するんです
だから煙を吸ったからと言って
脳細胞が壊れるという事はないんです
ただサイケデリック経験で
ハッピーになるんだそうです
吸ってる人々から聞けば
すごいハッピーになるんだと
平和な人間になるんだと
ああいうのは仏教の立場
仏教の偏見から見れば
瞑想ではないんです
でもサマーディ世界です
でも仏教ではサマーディ瞑想とは
言わないんです
科学的にサマーディ世界
なぜならば身体に依存する事を
どんどん控える事だから
仏教がサマーディ瞑想っていうのは
心の悪感情を控えて欲しい
悪感情を控えて善感情だったら
成長しても構わない
そういうところで決まっています
はい
サマーディは
仏教のサマーディバーワナーの場合は
まず五戒などを守って
道徳的な人間になります
そこからプログラムは始まる
道徳を守って欲しいんです
これはもう決まり
バイパスはできません
道徳を守ると結構、私だけが偉い
という事はなくなっていくんです
次に物質世界の一つを選んで
全ての世間的な思考妄想をやめて
選んだ対象だけ念じるんです
あまり具体的に
言いたくはないんですけど
物質世界と言ったのは
自分の心が作った物質でしょう？
一つの物質を選んでその物質の名前を
念じるんです、それだけ
何も神秘がないんです
例えば水を選んだとしましょう
だから適当にプラスチックの
桶みたいなものに
水を入れて、色が見えるんですから
すごくまずいんだけど
湖とか大きい水だったら
やりやすいんです
大きい湖があるとこ、何処かでちょっと
木で座るところを作って
遠くまでと、水だけ見える
それで思考を止める
思考を止めるためには
水、水、水と唱えなくてはいけないです
言葉に出さなくてもいいんですけど
パーリ語だったら
āpo āpo āpo と、唱えるんです
ハチャメチャ
麻薬中毒みたいな感じで
ずーっと唱えるんです
そこで体の事をかなり
無視して欲しいんです
だから身体を動かしたり
あちら見たり、こちら見たり
カラスの声聞いたら
これ見たりとか瞑想にならない
全て無視して
水だけ唱えて念じているんです
それでどんどん心が
優先世界になってしまって
たったったったと
禅定が現れてきます
これ水、土を見る事もできるし
あるいは色を見る事もできるし
仏教世界から何を選んでもいいんだけど
例えばマイクロフォンを見て
瞑想しようと言っても
瞑想にならない、ちょっと複雑です
純物質ではないんです
対象と自分の認識が一体感を作ることで
進んでみます、作るところまで
何か今思い出した
湖に立てばいいんですよ
湖はこの外から見ると
岸とか見えるんですから面倒くさい
ではなくて
水のど真ん中に何か入れておいて
そこで座って水を見るんだったら
水しか見えない
何とかしなくてはいけない
そういう風に
あるいは何か木の梯子でも登って
そこで座ったら見ると水だけ見える
魚飛んだりとかボートが行ったりするとすごく混乱するんです
だから水は人工的に別な場所で
森の中でそういう風な水たまりとか
そういう風に選んだ方が
やりやすいんです
現代はなかなか難しいんですけど
地水火風のどちらでも対象にします
風はどうやって瞑想するか
私は分かりませんけど
どちらでも選べられるようになります
とにかく結果は簡単
対象と自分の認識が一体になるんです
ずっと水、水、水と念じた水
あの対象が自分になってしまうんです
それでサマーディが生まれたんです
それはすごく安らぎを感じます
ものすごい
最初の経験ではものすごく、びっくり
驚くぐらいの大胆な経験になるんです
全て消えてしまいますよ
だから、それで止めるなよと
また普通の五感に戻って
またやって下さいと
それで繰り返してみるんです
そうすると、あー大胆凄い事をやった
という気持ちが消えて落ち着くんです
それで科学的にサマーディ状況を
解説する事はできるんです
主体・客体の境目が消えたら
サマーディなのです
それから、そのサマリー状態を
繰り返し経験します
慣れたら、サマーディを
さらに向上させます
ただ一体になっただけでは足らない
もっともっとレベルアップしなくては
いけないんです
それのレベルはちゃんとあります
精密科学的に説かれていますから
やりたい方々は本を読んでみて下さい
はい、次にいきます
これ、対象を選ぶ
対象は何でもいいんです
ペーパー紙、何か例えばA4の紙
選んでも何でもいいんです
自分の世界だから
しかし
何でも良いわけでもないんです
自分の性格に合わない対象は
ゴキブリを取って
前に死んだゴキブリ入れて
ずーっと
ゴキブリさん、ゴキブリさんと
どうなるかわからない
でもそういう瞑想はありますよ
死体を見て瞑想するというのは
だから性格に合うか合わないか
チェックしなくてはいけない
だから指導者が弟子を調べて対象...
とにかくこの
時々感情がいきなり
爆発する場合があるんです
だからそういうものは
もう選ばない
仏教では、こんな面倒くさいんですから
一応40種類にリストが書いてある
この中から一つ選んで下さいと
どう選べば？
指導者に聞けと言うんです
この40のリストで
現代は実践できないものもあります
呼吸瞑想は誰にでも出来る
釈尊も推薦している方法です
これ、リストの中で呼吸瞑想があります
40の中で
呼吸瞑想をお釈迦様は
経典の中でもすぐ推薦しています
呼吸瞑想の種類はいくつかありますけど
インドの宗教がやっている
呼吸瞑想もありますけど
仏教でブッダが教えている呼吸瞑想が
中部経典のĀnāpānasutta経典
というものがありまして
それを読めばやり方がわかります
それから皆様に私が紹介している
慈悲喜捨もその40に入ってます
ですから皆様に慈悲喜捨は全部まとめて
瞑想するように紹介していますけど
私はそんな
大胆なサマーディなんかなくても
まともな人間になってもらえば
いいと思っていたんですけど
それもまだ成功していないし
サマーディを作るところまでは
サマーディを作りたく
慈悲喜捨の瞑想をやる場合は
少々瞑想のパターンを
変えなくてはいけない
慈悲喜捨というのは瞑想4つなんです
一つ選んでやらなくてはいけない
各人にどちらが適しているかと
やっぱりすごく厳しく
性格を調べて
選ばなくてはいけないんです
はい、次にいきます
論理はもう説明しましたけど
物質と心の関係で優先なのは
心だと発見する実践です
要するにquantum世界の紹介です
招待です、サマーディ瞑想で
眼・耳・鼻・舌・身・意に触れる
色・声・香・味・触・法の対象から
一つ選んでそれに集中することです
だから音を選んで瞑想してもいいんです
でも同じ音を1時間2時間ぐらい一定して
聞こえるか、ないかわからない
音の場合は人工的な音よりは
自然の音の方がよろしいし
だから太鼓やら神社仏閣で使っている
うるさい音を、チベット仏教でも
あれはいくらか
集中してもらおうという狙いなんです
意門には過去・未来・現在
実在する/実在しない
如何なる法も入りますから
推薦されている瞑想対象だけにします
色・声・香・味・触・法の場合は
簡単です
法、意門、心だけで瞑想する場合は
気を付けて対象を選ぶんです
仏教が推薦するのは
仏隨念、法隨念、無常念、苦念
無我隨念などです
例えば無常隨念をやりたい場合は
サマーディ瞑想で
ヴィパッサナーではないんです
何を見ても
あーそれは、無常で消えていく事に
アプローチを入れるんです
川を見て、あぁきれいな川
ではなくて、あぁ流れて行くんだ
瞬間、瞬間消えるんだと
花を見たら瞬間
これ瞬間、瞬間枯れていくでしょうと
葉っぱを見たら、あぁ
じわじわとこれ、衰えて落ちるだろう
例えば新しい服を買った買ってきた服を
ビニール袋からはずして着るでしょう？
着た瞬間で古着になるでしょうと
という風な感じで
アプローチを変えて普通にいる
そうするとこの瞑想っていうのは
すごくやりやすい
仏教で必ず優先する瞑想で特別行を
やらなくても日常でできるんです
不浄観
物事は綺麗っていうのは見た目だけだと
それから慈悲喜捨などは
心だけでやる瞑想
眼を使って瞑想する
耳を使って瞑想するとかありまして
あまり鼻を使ってやる瞑想はないんです
テキストでは
創造者・支配者・管理者が
心だと実証することで
心次第で現象は変化するのだと
体験することもできます
全部、心だと
沙門果経などではお釈迦様は
この瞑想の説明をするところは
そこら辺はやっぱり全部心だよ
というステージで
サマーディ瞑想の所にいって
それから、ちょっと
quantumに挑戦するんです
一番最初の事だけ
面白いから言います、自分が本当に
自分はquantumだと、心だと
心が物質を作って、この物質の中に
いわゆる身体を作っているんだと
だったら別な身体も作れない？
コピーするんです
自分を
それには第四禅定まで経ってないと
できません
でもお釈迦様の経典を見てみると
第一、二間でもできます
アビダルマでは第四です
と言うんですけど
第一、二、大丈夫だけど
第四にしましょう、安全のために
四まで禅定に達したら
なんだ全部心が作っているんだと
この身体、心が作っているんだと
では試そう
試すために
一つコピーを作ってみるんです
そうするとまるっきり自分のコピーが
そこで具体的に現れるんです
だからこの身体が一つの
物を入れるあれや、まるいやつ
そんな型を例え使ってもその中から
中身を出すような感じで
中、心がいるんだから
心がそこからもう一つ身体を作って出す
またもう一度身体を作って出す
もう一度身体を作って
何体でも作って出す事ができます
でもそこをコントロールするのは
一つの心ですから
そこですぐ分かります
これは作ったものだと
例えば作った人が立ったら
コピーは全部立ちます
作った修行者がこんにちはと言うと
周りのコピーみんな
こんにちはと言うんです
同じ時間で
時間ずれません
これで作ったものという事は
分かります
それで一般...
三次元世界にいる人にとっては
どちらが本物か、どちらが偽物か
わからないんです
また幾つかありますよ
心で決めて、いろんな事をやるという
はい、次に行きます
サマーディだけで
今日終わってしまうみたい
すごい時間なくなった
サマーディはステージがあります
４つあります
ベースが主体・客体の差が
なくなること
1、第一のサマーディステージは
色・声・香・味・触・法の対象から
認識が離れること
眼に見える...眼と耳、鼻、舌と身体
対象から離れるんです
だから一般的に言えば
我を忘れる状態に
それは必要です
心に悪感情は起きない
悪感情はない
しかし思考があるんです
瞑想に言葉を使っていますから
五欲から離れた安らぎと
喜悦感を経験する
ものすごい喜悦感を経験する
びっくりするくらい
安穏感、喜悦感を経験する
それはだいたい物理的
お釈迦様が言うのは身体の全細胞に
喜びの感じが入るんだと
我々が、あぁ楽しかったワイワイという
脳みその錯覚ではないんです
特別な喜悦感なんです
身体、細胞たちが感じるんです
パーリ語のセクションを入れたんだけど
時間もないんですから
もう省略して、2番目のサマーディは
思考はちょっと停止するんです
思考が停止したということは
対象と一つになって、なってしまって
考える必要がなくなってしまったんです
思考があるという事は
念じる事で水だったら水、水、水、水と
念じる事で一緒になっています
それはいらなくなってしまうんです
ブッダがサマーディと言うのは
それなんです、思考を止めたから
一般的には一部サマーディですけど
お釈迦様の経典では
サマーディというのは
第2番目からなんです
これで激しい喜悦感、感情がなくなって
何かすごく落ち着いた
楽を感じるんです
それも全細胞で感じるんです
はい、三番目
3番目ではこの楽しい喜悦感...で
喜悦を超えて楽のみを感じる
落ち着いているんです、何か楽です
これは超越した楽なんです
捨の気持ちでいるし、気づきだけがある
気づきがあるんです
例えば呼吸瞑想を対象にしたならば
空気に気づきがあるんです
空気が行ったり来たり、行ったり来たり
来る時、ずーっと知っているだけで
それだけ、身体は楽
すごい、超気持ちいい
それもないんです
落ち着いて
極限に落ち着いてる状態
4番目は喜も楽もなくて
他の楽しい悲しい
そういうものも全くなくて
捨と言う時は
なんとなく何にも動揺しない
クール、冷静な状態が現れるんです
これ、サマーディというのは
冷静っていうのは
身体全体なる事なんです
それは4番目で、それから思考を使って
心が体を作っていることを発見すると
quantumの実験もできるようになります
それからこの物質に全く依存しないで
心を物質から離してもらって
心だけ成長する、成長させ育てる
サマーディ、4つがあるんです
今日はそれは説明できない
難し... くはないんですけど時間がない
はい、次に行きます
はい、これで
サマーディバーワナーは終わり
それから智慧のバーワナー
どうしますかね？
まぁ苦労する羽目になりますけど
このまま時間ないんですけど
ぱっぱっと大事な
これは皆様に教えてますから
ヴィパッサナー瞑想として
まぁ省略してもいいとは思います
情報を合成したり、捏造したりしないで
客観的
普遍的な実体を
認識する能力です
この智慧のバーワナーというのは
サマーディは心を強くするんです
智慧のバーワナーっていうのは
認識能力を
だから、すごい心があったから
と言っても役に立たないでしょうね
使ってみなければ
心の仕事は認識すること
だから今まで心は
幻覚を認識していたんです
ハチャメチャ勘違いしていたんです
それを直すんです、はい
ヴィパッサナーという観察能力
このバーワナーで
心の認識能力を上げるのです
普通は情報を合成して
捏造して認識します
我々は情報を捏造するんです
あって欲しいままを認識します
例えばこの花は
まるっきり自然ではないでしょう？
我々の感情で
我儘、好き勝手で変えたでしょう？
いわゆる自然をいじったんです
現実を変えて幻覚を作ったんです
これは明らかに幻覚なんです
花は植物ですから
そこ、咲いたところで
本来の姿の花があるんです
切って、これ刺した時点で
幻覚なんです
これをずーっとやってます
あって欲しいままに認識する
それが出来ると
欲の感情と愛着
できない場合は
怒りの感情と執着
または無知の感情を作ります
例えばあって欲しいままに見る
例えばマイクロフォンが
クリスタルになって欲しいと私は思う
思ってみても何だ、ただのプラスチックでできててつまらない
あぁクリスタルで
あった方がいいのにとか
そこで私に嫌な気持ちが起きてしまって
また、執着も生まれます
レストランでご飯
注文したらそこで
おいしいという事を期待しているんです
それで食べてみたらまぁ
希望通りに、あぁやっぱり希望通りに
美味しいと思ったら
欲が生まれるんです
どちらでも執着が生まれるんです
ヴィパッサナーは
この心の欠陥を直します
これは心の欠陥なんです
心の仕事は認識する事でしょう？
お前、認識しなさい
こいつは認識しないんです
何かカラクリをやって
認識したという事にするんです
定規が曲がっているといくら頑張っても
一直線は描けないんです
もっと頑張れ、もっと頑張れって
意味がないでしょう
定規を直すしかないんです
だから心に情報を捏造するという
病気があるんです
情報を知れない
認識できないという
弱みがあるんです
だから捏造するんです
科学者たちは顕微鏡で
ちっちゃな物を見たりすると
例えば微生物の研究する方々とか
遺伝子の研究をする
何か色を付けてしまうんです
対象に
色を付けてしまうと自分が見たい事が
見えるんです、見たい事
そんな感じで
我々は情報を捏造するんです
現象はありのままに観察できると
真理を認識します
それで真理を知ったら
まんまと騙されていたんだと
わかるんです
一切の煩悩・執着が
切断します、はい次に行きます
この瞑想はすぐできる
サマーディ瞑想には
いろんな準備があります
これにはないんです
思考・妄想をストップして
体とこころに触れる情報に
気づくことから始めます
だから認識はここで生まれる
目に触れること、体に触れること
そこから始まります
思考・妄想全てストップで間違いだから
捏造をしてあって欲しいままに
する事はナノ秒の早さで起こるので
時間をかけて
訓練する必要があります
私が教えている膨らみ縮みとか
体の感覚です
膨らみに何も価値を入れません
希望を入れません
お腹が勝手に膨らむで、それに合わせて
膨らみ膨らみと確認するだけ
でも捏造は簡単にやめません
簡単にストップできません
理由はこの、ナノ秒の世界なんです
心は
ですから訓練して、訓練して
捏造をしないところまで
訓練しなくてはいけないんです
気づきのみの実践で
捏造機能をストップするという事が
これは理論です
気づきだけをしていると
捏造機能は止まるでしょうと
我々は瞑想でそれを期待しているんです
残りはフリーでオートで起こるんです
捏造が止まったら
その人は現実を見るんです
ありのままに、現実を認識するんです
はい、次に行きます
これ順番
認識能力を上げて、バイアス、感情
捏造の壁を徐々に
無くしていく過程なので
順番には悩む必要はありません
ヴィパッサナー瞑想をする方々は
順番はどうかと... いらない
教えたレッスンをやって下さい
それをやると次のレッスンが
次にあるんです
これは精密科学で
お釈迦様が考えた瞑想ですから
お釈迦様は智慧で教えた瞑想ですから
まずこれをやってくださいと
これをやった人は次に
このレベルに達しますと
それで、また同じことを続ければ
仕事はただ観察だけです
レベルはどうであっても
だから順番は悩まない、誰も
次のステージを知っても
無理に飛ぶこともできません
ヴィパッサナー瞑想で
時々私にも訊きますよ
次、何がありますか、とか
これが終わったら何がありますかと
何人かに教えたんです
あなた次にこういう事を経験しますと
次にこういう事を経験します
それでこの人はいきなり
あっそういう事を私は経験しましたと
言ってきたんです、あぁやれやれと
この人は仏道を破壊したんだと、本人の
こんなインチキ、ごまかしはできません
精進さえすれば自然に進みます
智慧が現れるのが遅いとき
進まないとき、妄想が起きたとき
ブッダの言葉を学んで理解するのです
瞑想で何か壁にぶつかったとか
何か同じ、足踏み状態だと思ったら
何か経典を開けて読んでみてください
その時、ものの見事にあなたに
ぴったり合う経典がみつかるんです
サマーディ瞑想から実践する人には
quantum世界を試してみるセクションも
お釈迦様が説かれて...
これは説明しました
それからまたヴィパッサナーを
始めなくてはいけないですよ
quantumがわかったからと言って
解脱ではないんです
これは順番です
はい、また順番ありますけど
ヴィパッサナーの流れという事を
書いていますけど
実践する自分の体、物質ですね
と認識している心が一定しないで
変化して流れることに気づく
ここであまり一体感ではないんです
例えば自分が膨らみ縮みと
確認しているでしょう？
心が
変わるわ、変わるわ、変わるわ
膨らみ縮みも
観察する心も変わる
観察される対象も変わる
同じものをリピートしない
それを発見します
愛着・期待・希望が認識を汚すと
絶望という苦が生じることを理解する
瞑想の中でそれは起きます
ちょっと瞑想していると
何かすごく体が楽になっ たと
あぁ楽になった、俺は進んでいると
調子に乗るでしょう？
あれ煩悩です、次に瞑想したら
最低最悪地獄に落ちたような
苦しみを感じるんです
妄想がざーっと攻撃して
丸っきり初心者よりも
以下のレベルに落ちるんです
それで苦しむんです
あぁ何ということかと
私には能力が無いでしょうか、とか
そこで宗教家に行くような感じで私に
助けてくださいとか何とか...
私は宗教家ではないんですから
ものすごい厳しい言葉で
怒鳴ることはできます
だってバカな事を
やってしまったんですから
調子に乗るなよと言っていたのに
だから調子に乗ったのは
愛着でしょ？希望でしょ？
あっ、これから瞑想は楽ちん
希望でしょ？
こうならない、それですぐ学べる
希望、イコール酷い苦しみです
ひどい落ち込みです
成長とは何にも希望しない
ということです
希望通りにいくことではないんです
今皆様にとっては幸福は
希望通りの人生が流れること
これは無知な世界
一切希望しないことは智慧の世界
心が物質の激しい変化に気づくと
自我が成り立たないと発見します
心は変化する
物質は変化する
これ自我が、自分がいないんです
自我が成り立たないと
愛着・執着・煩悩は減っていく
そこまで煩悩はそのまま元気です
あぁ自分とは成り立たないねと
わかると煩悩が弱くなっているんです
煩悩が絶対成り立たないと
発見する事が智慧の完成であり
解脱というんです
それで修行は終わります
再び現象に執着しない状態になるので
プログラムは終了です
大体ヴィパッサナーの流れは
そういう流れで
結構難しいんですから
理解できないかもしれません
時間もないし
はい、次に行きます
智慧のステージがあります
自我の錯覚が消えたら預流果といいます
怒りと欲の感情が控えた所で
一来果というんです
怒りと欲の感情が
きれいさっぱり消えたら
不還果と言うんです
自分がいるという自覚すら
なくなったら
阿羅漢と言うんです
それが４つのステージです
これで終了でしょうね
はいそういうことで
別な日でまた喋るしかないんです
ありがとうございます、これで終了です
では時間、終わりになりましたので
祈願で終了します
Dukkhappattā ca niddukkhā
Bhayappattā ca nibbhayā
Sokapattā ca nissokā
Hontu sabbepi pāṇino
苦しんで悩む生命が苦しみなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますように
Sādhu! Sādhu! Sādhu!
どうもありごとうございます